- [Interviewer] Okay, Audy.
Audy, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Audy] I growed up in Indiana
till I was eight year old.
And then my dad retired and moved back
to his home place in
Leslie County, Kentucky.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
growing up as a kid?
- Up till I was 12 year old, 11 year old.
Then my mom and dad separated.
- [Interviewer] And who raised you then?
- My dad, and I stayed
with my mom sometimes,
but not much, because I started
going down the wrong path.
- [Interviewer] What kind of
stuff were you getting into?
- Drugs. Smoking weed, and
doing pill called Xanax
and Percocet.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- 46 year old.
- [Interviewer] 46?
- Be 46 in January, the 19th.
- [Interviewer] So that
was kind of the beginning
of the drug problem here in Appalachia?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How far
did you go in school?
- Eighth grade.
- [Interviewer] Eighth grade?
And did you go to work
at some point there?
- Yeah. I worked all my life.
Out of these hills, I worked
a few tax-paying jobs.
But I dig roots called yam, cohosh,
we call it rattle weed, and stone root.
In the winter-time now.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- In the summer I dig
ginseng and yellow root.
And strip elm trees.
- [Interviewer] Of their bark?
- On private property. Yeah.
People let's us have them cause
they're no good for lumber.
You can't saw them up for lumber.
- [Interviewer] But the bark is?
- The bark is valuable.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. And
you, like this ginseng,
you sell to Chinese?
- Well, I sell them to
local dealers around here.
- [Interviewer] To a middle man.
- Ever who pays the most, you know,
that's who I sell to.
And that's what they do with it.
They sell it to the Chinese.
And that's where your most money is,
is in ginseng and yellow root.
- [Interviewer] And this is,
the life here in Appalachia,
especially in the mountains,
it's a tough life, right?
It's a difficult way to survive.
- Yeah. It's real tough.
Cause the way I done dig,
I'd have to take a mattock
and dig these out of
the ground, one by one.
And when they're just worth a
couple cents a root, you know,
it takes a lot of roots
to make a hundred dollars.
It's a lot of digging,
that's two good sacks
is a hundred dollars.
I'm talking about sacks, like this.
You can imagine how many
roots this round will go
into one sack.
That be, probably three,
400 roots, if not more.
And that's three or 400 times,
I have to dig a hole down
in the ground to get it out.
So it's rough.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Do you love your life here in Appalachia?
- I love it.
- [Interviewer] What are your
favorite things about it?
- The hills is my number
one favorite thing about it
and being able to go in
and out of them, you know,
when I want to, 'cause they
got diamond trails and stuff.
We dig roots out them too.
It's for water trails.
It goes for miles and
miles through these hills.
And I ride my four-wheeler
along there and I'll stop.
And like a swag, we
call it or a small hole.
Go down in 'em, look for roots.
You know, to me every day I have to work,
just about every day to survive.
And know I've done everything
in the world to survive.
I've sold pills, I've sold pot.
But all that's behind me.
I don't do that crap no more.
I just work for everything I get now,
easy money is never good money.
- [Interviewer] And what
are the worst things
about living here?
What's the hardest part?
Just that you have to work so much?
- 'Cause, there ain't no jobs,
you know, no good paying jobs.
If you get it sure, you have
to have a house or you know
like working out the
hills or you may work,
be a carpenter or something.
I can get odd jobs and just
enough to feed yourself with
is about how you make.
- [Interviewer] Mm-hmm. I mean,
it's one of the poorest
parts of the country.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And everyone
is going through the same,
a similar struggle.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Is that
what makes everyone
so helpful to each other?
- Yeah. Somebody ain't
got a place to stay.
I've took a many a person in my home.
And then you didn't see my
home, I got a tiny home.
You see them tiny homes that's on TV.
I see that and I wanted
me and my wife to have one
and that's what I'd done.
I'm still working on it
slowly, but I'll get there.
As I get the money, you know,
most days I just make 30,
$40 a day, you know.
But there's some days
I can make a hundred.
At the end of the week,
I guess it averages up
to a couple hundred dollars, 250 a week.
If we have a decent week.
Now the bark pulling,
you can only do it three
months out of a year.
Now that's real good money.
You can make up or $500 a
week, but it's just for that
short period of time
that still don't help you
the rest of the year.
And when it's 20 degrees out
and you have to get up
at 5:30 in the morning,
it's still dark and get on
a cold four-wheeler ATV.
You know, that's what we go to work on,
you can't get a vehicle
or we go and it's rough.
You know, I can't afford no side beside
or I could get something
that had a little heat in it.
You know, then.
- [Interviewer] So to heat
your home, you use what?
- I use propane.
I can get a voucher down here
that helps me out with it.
And at LKLB.
- [Interviewer] Have you traveled,
have you been around the country?
- Yeah, I've been to Chicago,
you know, Ohio, Indiana.
And this place you like asked, you know.
- [Interviewer] Do you
ever consider leaving?
- Yeah, I probably
would if I had a vehicle
and could get a insurance on it.
Yeah, I'd go where there was good jobs at,
that way I know I'm
making five or six a week.
My brother, he made
good money out his life
and well he had a heart
attack and had to quit.
He ain't much older than
me, just five years older.
But the coal mines, they make
a old man out of a young man,
you know, he gets old before his time.
Yeah. I most definitely growed up hard.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Do you have children?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No kids.
- No, no children.
- [Interviewer] If you did, would you -
- See yeah, well I got step children,
I got a little step-grand boy
I play with almost every day.
You know, every day he comes out.
- [Interviewer] And what do
you think about his future?
If he stays here?
- I think he will get, you
know, my nephew's stuff there.
They all got like two,
maybe three college degrees.
Well, my one nephew does,
he's a mortician and a what?
A registered nurse,
national nurse practitioner.
- [Interviewer] But he stayed here?
- Yeah, but he might go to another county.
Where 'cause the nurse
right now or that Obamacare,
one reason nurses jobs
good to have right now.
They give him,
like a one place offered him
10,000 bonus to sign, you know?
And that's just 10,000
and sign with them for
I guess so many years, you
know, sign a contract with them.
Ask me he's his best offer,
at $30 they're starting out.
I just don't got the education for it.
I was in special-ed and never
could learn to read and write.
- [Interviewer] Mm-hmm.
- So I had to get smart in other ways.
Street smart.
- [Interviewer] Do you
consider yourself a hillbilly?
- Oh yeah. I'm hillbilly to the bone.
All my people that did live in Indiana,
here's where they come from.
You know, it was Leslie County.
- [Interviewer] And you're proud of that?
- Yeah. I'm proud of it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. It's a-
- 'Cause we, it was just like at Hank
when we was juniors, home.
You know a country boy can survive
and these country boys
will and can survive.
- [Interviewer] And you're happy here?
- [Audy] Oh, I love it.
Won't be nowhere but the mountains.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any regrets?
- [Audy] Now, huh? No.
- [Interviewer] And do you
feel like you've lived the life
that you wanted to?
- [Audy] Yeah. Oh, I've loved my life.
I love it 'cause I met my
wife and I was married to her.
She passed away a year and half ago.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I'm sorry.
- [Audy] And her name was Reva Jean Kelly.
That was the best thing happened to me,
it helped get me off drugs and stuff.
- [Interviewer] Oh she did?
- [Audy] Yeah, you know,
that's the reason I quit,
was for her.
Cause you know, I've said it's my fault
that she was on 'em.
Cause you know how you act.
If you're doing something
most time in here,
in this country part,
they want to do it too.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. So you started it,
you got her getting used to it?
- Kel was already get started,
but that ain't what killed her.
You know what killed her?
She drunk bad water or
eat some type of bad meat.
And it gave her a brain disease.
They said that only 600
people in the world got it.
You know, around the world
most time it's not here,
it's in a foreign country or something
where they have to drink bad water.
- [Interviewer] And
that's what killed her?
- [Audy] UK hospital told us that anyway.
- [Interviewer] That's what killed her?
- Yeah. That's what killed her.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry.
- She was just as good
as we are right now.
And five minutes later, we'd laid down,
she tapped me on the shoulder
and said her right arm didn't move.
And then from there, she
just got worser every day,
five weeks, she was dead.
Them spots had moved to her motor skills
and parts of her brain.
I guess it worked her motor skills
and she didn't have no
control over her arms or legs.
I tried to give her medicine.
It helped some kept her
from, her arms from jerking
and her legs would just kick like that.
You know, she was in bad shape.
Hated seeing her go like that.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- Don't do drugs.
That's the message I can send to anybody,
that if they watch this, don't do drugs.
If you just starting, quit now
'cause they ruin your life.
I could had anything I wanted,
if I wasn't been a drug addict.
Could've lived in a brick home right now
and had new vehicles sitting in the yard.
'Cause I woulda had a good job
but I wasn't have been a drug addict.
And I wasted a lot of money.
I'm a little crippled up now from car.
I got three bad ricks and that
last rick wasn't long ago,
I ricked the forward broke my
back, both sides and my ribs.
And when I'd pee, I'd pee
that blood and that was,
that's been right before
I went cold, sober.
you know, that's what,
another thing that made me go cold, sober.
I made three times that I
got in a real bad accident.
One of them killed a guy,
you know, I was driving us
it killed him instantly, my
first cousin, my dad's nephew.
And I said, no more than that.
I went to a detox in Hazard for four days.
And then they put me in a
Suboxone clinic and it works.
If you do what they tell you, it works.
You will get off drugs.
And that's the message
I got for young people.
Don't do 'em.
If you're fooling with them
right now, stop while you can.
You can stop when you're young,
when you get older, it's real bad.
When you have to try to quit,
it takes five times as long.
- [Interviewer] All right, Audy.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story
and good luck with your life from here.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Hope you
find a lot of roots in the
in the hills this winter.
- Oh I'll find 'em.
Me and that old dude named Corbad,
we worked together for the last 26 years.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have good friends here?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I don't got a whole lot.
Because a whole lot of
people is no good here.
And some people is, people
what's around here today
is good people, where I'm at right now.
- [Interviewer] The drugs
that have kind of taken
over the younger generation.
- Yeah it's still in
younger and older people.
It's ruining them too.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But the ones that's just starting,
there's a good chance for them
now, the ones that's just,
for the young people they got
a chance to quit right now
because they've not done them that long
if they are doing 'em.
And if they ain't doing
them, never touch them
because you'll be like me and have nothing
but a little tiny home to live in.
And for the older people
there's help for them too.
Cause I was one of the
worsest drug addicts
in Leslie County.
- [Interviewer] You were?
- Yeah. And at one time,
one of the biggest dealers.
I let my mom and stepdad sell
for me and they got busted
and they said it was the
biggest in five counties.
I didn't make a lot of money
but I'd never go back to that.
I want my money the right way,
you know, I want to earn it.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Audy, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] And good luck
in the mountains this winter.
- [Audy] Okay.
- [Interviewer] Thank you man.